So, we now have a token
based authentication system
that will authenticate a user based on
their user name and password or a token.
But if we were going to actually store
passwords, users will be forced to make
accounts and remember another
password in order to use our API.
In a real application,
we would need to implement some sort of
account verification and
password recovery for
our application, since users can
often forget their passwords.
And users would need to fill out another
profile and probably upload another
profile picture, adding more delay time
for the user to access our application
and potentially introducing a place for
a loss in user retention.
If we add OAuth 2.0 to our application,
we can let users log in with their
existing accounts, like Google and
Facebook, and
quickly gain access to our application.
In this next video, I will show you how
to add an endpoint using Google signin
that will allow users to log in with
their existing Google accounts.